D
AND OTHERSE AUDIENCE SEE EIN- >.
THEYGHERK THAN ME, SO  TO MYRANO
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE THEM D.ISIM
GRANDMOTHER WHO WA
TEACHER AT THEUTD COUNTY
SCHOOL SYSTEM DI
BECAUSE SOMEON WEARINGMASK.
THIS IS A IS IS R
VERY --
>>- .
EAHEAD. THANK AVOIDABLE ISSUE, ,
IT'S IRRESPONSLE.
WE'RE KILLING PEOPLE
THIS IS NOT SOME WE
SHOULD BE
FOR THE EDUCATION  ANYO ME NO TE
THAT YOU JUST SAW SPEAKING AND S
WILL SEVERN.
GRADY, THANK YOU SO MUCHOR
COMING ON.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU MY HEART RTSH
YOU WERE TALKING
THAT IS SO
INPAINFUL.ST W GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND DURING TT NT.
>> MAIN WAS JU LIKOVER THE P ILT
LIKE THE TWO TT NNECTED BECAUSE
UNDERSTA WHY PE
LI
STATEMTHADTHLIKE SO PERSONAL, Y
MAKE A POINT OF WHAT WAS AT
>> SO,N ADVOCATINGLS FOR MONTHS.
ISHAT AFFECTS
THE NATION.
E SEEN THAT A LOT OF
STUDENTS, NOT JUST AS TENNESSEE
HAVE HAD TO MA A DIS
THAT ITO PRIORITIZE LTH OR THEI
ACICCAUSE NOW A  OPTIONS
LITEOF STUDENTS WERE QUARANTINED
JUST L ALONEBECAUSE TESES NO RN
RECEIVING NOINSTRUCTION.
SOMETIMESY'PTOMORTACTOUTSIDE O
MASKINT SAYS THIS.E
MASKS THE BOARD PREVIOUSLY TMAKO
ILP TO THE B TO
DEDEASK PO. WHA
DANDTH WILL BE  WEIRD BECAUSE AS
BECAUSE THERE' MDS
THNG C
MANY KIDS ROWITH HAPREADING SO
QUICTHAT -HER
PATHE VICEALS, TONE THAT'S CCT
LIG CONTACTRACED.ALND EVERYON J
AND THE VICE PRINCIPAL KNOWS  AE
IT'S NOT BECAUSE SDET ABOU
>> OF COSE.
IT,YOU KNOW, YOU SAID
U WERE SAYING WHAT
YOU'RE NOTIST E DOING. BEHIND Y
S YOUR MESSAGE TO THOSE
PARENTS WHO HED AT YOU>> IT HOPH
CHAN NSP FRONT OF
TIRE NATION AN ABOUTHOS ARE
SOMETH
OPEN.TIAL FO STAY
AND I HOPET THEYEE
THISS REALT BENEFITI E THAT BEL
MASKS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
YOUR LOSS ANSS
YOUR FAMILY OF YOUR GRANDMOTHER.
I KNHERY